bienvenue pour le 7-8 lecture téléphiles
60,18 votre rendez vous quotidien avec l
information locale le vendredi également
voici donc les principaux titres la
fédération française des motards en
colère organise régulièrement des
actions de sensibilisation sur le
terrain pour inciter elle est passionnée
encore plus de prudence sur la route
nouveau relais calmos samedi en vallée
de chevreuse vous seront proposés
informations routières ou encore
assistant ces techniques un espace à
bordeaux n'est devenue lieu
d'imagination artistique à carrières
sous poissy le château van der bilt est
devenu château éphémère la 2000 mètres
carrés pour une dizaine d'ateliers à
vocation pluridisciplinaire et un
laboratoire numérique labellisé fab lab
et comme chaque fin de semaine
l'essentiel de l'actualité depuis lundi
de la journée nationale du don d'organes
à l'ouverture des soldes
coup d'envoi aujourd'hui vendredi du
solar decathlon pour la première fois
depuis sa création aux états unis en
2002 cette compétition universitaire
mondiale se tient en france et 7 à
versailles inauguration aujourd'hui 27
juin la compétition début de samedi 20
logements qui n'ont pour autre énergie
que le soleil elles sont montées dans
une partie du parc du château de
versailles là les concurrents sont des
étudiants issus d'écoles d'architecturé
de l'université de 16 pays sur place
olivier maniscalco jonathan vilma noms
recueillis à la réaction du maire d'aube
maire de versailles françois de mazières
y at il des favoris qui se détache c'est
la question qui lui ont posé je suis
venu plusieurs fois et et j'ai vu
plusieurs projets très intéressants je
suis incapable de vous dire qui sera le
rien parce que c'est un jury qui va
avoir plusieurs paramètres mais enfin
moi je suis
très passionné à la fois par les projets
à dimension aussi sociale puisque j'en
avais beaucoup il ya des préoccupations
notamment d un pays en voie
développement comment faire face aux
catastrophes naturelles comment faire
face à adé phénomène de surpopulation
pouvoir construire pas cher et puis
également par l'ansés nous plus est plus
proche les préoccupations de densité
urbaine et donc comment construire des
bâtiments existants du premier conseil
communautaire jeudi soir pour la
nouvelle équipe en place menée par le
maire de montigny le bretonneux michel
laugier un programme chargé pour cette
séance avec l'examen des comptes
administratifs le budget principal
dégageant un excédent de 3,1 millions
d'euros la dette quant à elle s'élever
en 2013 un peu plus de 359 millions
d'euros en diminution par rapport à 2012
à noter que deux audits ont été
commandés par la nouvelle majorité il
concerne la culture et l'élargissement
du périmètre de la communauté
d'agglomération à demain les
intercommunalités devront compter plus
de deux cent mille habitants quelques
messages clairs ont aussi était lancée
concernant l'office de tourisme par
exemple leur berger responsable ump de
l'opposition à magny les hameaux a
déclaré vouloir travailler à une
meilleure rationalisation en souhaitant
un projet plus rigoureux et plus
raisonnable politique toujours ce week
end samedi valérie pécresse réunit la
fédération des yvelines autour de
françois fillon et de bruno le maire le
co président de l'ump par intérim et le
député de l'eure sont attendus à jouy en
josas par les militants pour un déjeuner
champêtre au menu résultats des
dernières élections mais aussi crise
actuelle au sein de la formation
l'invité de ce vendredi à 27 juin jean
luc prévost bonjour et bienvenue chez
coordinateur dans les yvelines de la
fédération française des motards en
colère fédération qui entend à défendre
les usagers des deux ou trois roues et
vous préférez à la prise de conscience
aux mesures répressives
dans cette optique ce week end samedi 28
juin à cerner la ville banques je vous
laisse raccrocher votre téléphone se
déroulera au chalet des cascades
l'opération relais calmos s'est bien
accroché votre téléphone allez-y qu'est
ce qu'un relais calmos alors voilà un
relais calmos remonte c'est un concept
qui remonte à plus d'une vingtaine
d'années d'un qui consiste à installer
des points sur les notamment sur les
grands événements motards son appel on à
l'enduro du touquet on a le bol d'or on
a les 24 heures du mans
on a aussi le grand prix de france ainsi
que le superbike à ceux ci se rajoute
également des comme pour demain le
relais de chevreuse il en existe
également un puits s'il ya des soucis
également sur la route des crêtes dans
les gauches
choisi pour nom en voile absolument oui
on sait qu'il ya des soucis entre les
entre les motards et les riverains donc
il faut un petit peu calmé le jeu à ce
niveau là l'airé vous réconcilier avec
les riverains se serait calmée colère -
qui est le plus énervé on a dit on a des
gens chez nous qui ont des comportements
et un petit peu
anormaux donc il serait souhaitable que
ceux ci reviennent un petit peu dans les
règles parce que la vallée de chevreuse
et qui est un endroit très agréable il
ya moyen de si belles années en
endossant enquiquiner les riverains
justement est-ce que le message passe
facilement ou est-ce que auprès des
motards c'est quelquefois difficile de
vous faire entendre entendu vous voulez
un message citoyen vous voulez bonne
image pour les motards tout simplement
est-ce que c'est difficile parfois faire
entendre ça dépend ça dépend des
individus il y en a qui sont
complètement rebelles dont qui refuse
toute règle quelle qu'elle soit et puis
on a d'autres qui est effectivement par
manque d'information ou ne se rendent
pas bien compte ou des fois ils sont
conscients qu'ils peuvent être une gêne
et à ce moment par contre nous ne savons
pas si après ils changent leur
comportement mais le but c'est un petit
peu de faire savoir c'est aussi
l'occasion de faire de la prévention
peut être un petit peu alors que les
premiers départs en vacances vous
rapprochez vous sensibiliser aussi au
comportement sur la route faire
attention non seulement dans sa conduite
et puis à la conduite des autres des
automobilistes pareil voilà c'est ça
voilà on a eu l'occasion à ce niveau là
justement d'intervenir chez peugeot 2
justement pour notamment sensibiliser
les salariés sur l'usagé du téléphone
par exemple comment se passe les
rapports avec les automobilistes
justement je vous pose cette question
parce qu'il ya quelques jours la
fédération belge des motards en colère a
mené une action blocage à bruxelles pour
sensibiliser les conducteurs de voiture
je vais citer quelques chiffres qui
concerne la belgique par rapport au
chiffre de 2013 augmentation de 52 % du
nombre de motards blessés et de 15% des
motards tués ça se passe de la même
manière en france quels sont les
rapports avec les automobilistes 1
quelle est la situation nous nous sommes
la fédération française des motards en
colère et pour le portage leurs dons
qu'on partage là ceci étant dit ça se
passe plus ou moins bien ça dépend des
uns et des autres si vous tombez sur
deux personnes réfléchies tout se
passera bien si vous tombez sur deux
abrutis les choses se passent moins bien
voilà c'est tout simple parce que c'est
peut-être assez schématique mais on a
toujours l'impression contre les motards
et les automobilistes et c'est très
difficile d'avoir à laquelle campant sur
ses positions à dos juan nom comme ça je
vais je dis non sur la réalité sur le
terrain non non non non c'est quelques
individus à des comportements de de
certains individus ce qui nous amène à
parler peut-être un peu de sécurité
routière est ce que la politique du
gouvernement en la matière a donc bon
sens mais actuellement nous sommes
contre l'abaissement de la vitesse de 80
de 90 à 80 sur les routes secondaires
parce qu'on ne voit pas du tout on a
l'impression que les résultats de la
baisse des morts c'est plus que ça tient
plutôt du coup de louche qu'autre chose
parce que rien ne justifie un tel
chiffre donc voilà donc pour nous
explique un petit peu un peu
différemment les choses et on sait que
la vitesse est un facteur aggravant mais
mon avis si vous avez un accident 89-80
le résultat est à peu près identique à
résidence et pratique de tests pour
l'instant de passer à 80 km certains à
double sens de circulation
je n'ai pas d'accord avec ça non non
contre seulement contre ce test le vrai
problème c'est pour poursuivre les
motards en colère c'est l'état des
routes l'inattention voulons également
l'état des routes on a internet soit un
département où globalement les routes
sont très bonnes en carton bas dans
d'autres départements s'aperçoit tout de
suite de la différence donc estivaux là
on n'a pas trois semaines par contre il
y a des parfois de l'installation
d'infrastructures qui sont complètement
aberrante là c'est au niveau que je
dirais plutôt des communes par exemple
dernièrement on nous a montré des photos
de hertz qui soit installée
à l'entrée de thoiry mais où c'est qu'on
va quoi c'est des trucs de moyen-âge en
revient des trucs
ils sont même pas réfléchi qu'un enfant
pouvait se blesser sur ce genre
d'obstacles on va c'est complètement
aberrant voilà où on a les potées de
louveciennes aussi un motard qui tombe
dans le virage d'ailleurs nous allons
essayer de faire un peu tôt installée de
la végétation basse qui empêcherait le
stationnement aussi mais qui serait
quand même moins dangereux si un motard
tomber justement vous arrivez à vous
faire entendre quels sont les rapports
vous allez quand on est un défaut
d'infrastructures niveau du conseil
général n'y a pas de souci ça se règle
assez facilement vous êtes m'a consulté
en amont c'est toujours après alors
hélas oui c'est ça et là c'est dommage
ça engage des travaux
mais on a
on a une une fédération en loire
atlantique qui a signé une charte
concernant les infrastructures et la
communauté urbaine de nantes alors j'ai
reçu ça il ya très peu de temps je pense
que l'on va essayer de faire quelque
chose visite conseil général au maître
1,7 en juillet avant ici ont surpris
alors ce qui à ce qui manque par exemple
c'est sûr il manque un contrôle les
infrastructures on contrôle tout parti
quand notre pays on n'est pas une
voiture comme ça en service sans la
contrôler et s'est essayée et les
infrastructures non d'un passant qu'un
marchand de tapis se présente dans une
mairie il va vous installé un tapis dans
devant devant la mairie par exemple a
laissé un peu sancoins j'exagère mais
c'est ça donc faut arrêter quoi il faut
un petit peu plus de services nous là il
faudrait du contrôle d'infrastructures
les motards en colère aujourd'hui dans
les yvelines en tout cas ça représente
quoi vous êtes combien alors nous sommes
trois cent cinquante adhérents
mutuellement c'est en stagnation où ça
augmente régulièrement installés en une
petite baisse qu'on était jusqu'à 400
l'an passé nous avons une petite bête on
ignore un petit peu les raisons pour
lesquelles on a je sais qu'on a des gens
qui ont des soucis économiques qui ne
peuvent parler des red hot avec la moto
enfin il ya différents motifs donc voilà
ces différentes opérations dont le
relais calmos dont nous avons parlé tout
à l'heure il ya d'autres actions qui
sont prévues
à l'arôme intervient dans les collèges
ou au sein du ne soit pas une commission
éducation routière de la jeunesse
dans lequel on essaye notre sur notre
nous portons notre
notre sujet sur les relations entre le
cerveau et la vision faire prendre
conscience aux enfants que des fois le
cerveau et la vision ça ne fonctionne
pas bien il ya des petits décalages
sachant que les enfants bien souvent se
penchent donc parfait donc leur montrer
que malgré tout le d'êtres humains est
quand même quelque chose des fois de
faillible merci jean luc prévost anota
et citoyen c'est votre mot d'ordre et
samedi 28 juin à cerner la ville vous
organisez une nouvelle fois en relais
calmos 10h 18h merci d où le roi on
continue ce journal
nous allons maintenant revenir sur les
principales informations de cette
semaine et mercredi coup d'envoi des
soldes d'été des soldes très attendu si
l'on en croit les sondages entre 76 et
82 % d'entre nous auraient l'intention
de faire de bonnes affaires comment
s'est passé le premier jour de
promotions côté commerçants la direction
le centre commercial when the sun
parisseaux clayes sous bois c'est un
centre commercial particulier qui
pratique depuis son ouverture il ya
moins d'un an le déstockage des marques
de luxe car combien
premier jour des soldes d'été ce
mercredi dans les magasins les premiers
clients pracc les bonnes affaires c'est
très important parce que
il ya toutes les tailles non c'est sympa
de venir le premier jour ça va je ne
pouvais pas m'en acheter quand c'était
un sens et qu'elle l'a ses attentes 1
donc moi je vois que ça me va c'est pour
tout le monde car ici on solde des
articles des collections passées déjà
des griffes et comme beaucoup de
français cette année ses clients
privilégient l'achat de vêtements et de
chaussures et les ventes devraient être
bonnes selon un sondage du conseil
national des centres commerciaux
76% des français comptent faire les
soldes cinq points de plus que l'année
dernière dans cette boutique elle
représente 25% du chiffre d'affaires
annuel c'est des grosses périodes 1 pour
moi c'est les plus grosses périodes de
l'année un peu moins que les soldes
d'hiver parce que les articles sont un
peu moins cher cd - grosse caisse mais
on ne tipi par 4,5 à 6 dans ce magasin
pour hommes également on compte sur les
soldes pour booster les ventes on va
vous arriver une période calme et il ya
une heure on était en plein rush et on a
passé une heure intense qu'est ce qu'on
attend de ces soldes
par l'affluence bien évidemment une
multipliés comme l'iphone chiffre
d'affaires par dix
ici chaque année le e-commerce se gagne
des parts de marché cette athlète se
veut confiant le commerce traditionnel
reste une valeur sûre parce qu'on
propose justement des notions de service
la facilité avec toucher le produit puis
surtout la relation humaine le conseil
il reste cinq semaines pour dénicher les
bonnes affaires les soldes se
termineront le mardi 29 juillet
et cotées consommateurs comment se passe
le début des soldes quelques réponses
avec ce micro-trottoir pas ce rapidement
parce que les enfants sont pas très
patient mais ça se passe bien côté
quelque chose qui me plaît l'achète
quand ça me plaît pas je sais pas mais
très bien il n'y a pas trop de monde
c'est parfait et on appris ce qu'est ce
qu'on avait besoin sa dépense beaucoup
d'argent ça va ça se passe très très
bien mais quand même si un peu plus cher
qu'aux la dernière fois on va dire d'ici
cinq ou six mois derrière voilà mais
quand même là ça reste on a fait un très
bien je sais que de faire des affaires
pour ma fille pour ma petite fille mon
mari et moi même très bien très bien
dépense pas de sous une fois que j'ai
l'occasion de venir un mercredi matin
dès le début des soldes je suis là il
revient de conseil idc là et j'ai acheté
100 euros et checa congé
économiser 80 ans je ne pense pas pas
plus je vais m'arrêter là et gare aux
arnaques pendant les soldes de l'ufc que
choisir intervient pour protéger les
consommateurs sont responsables sur
versailles et sa région était un autre
invité cette semaine je vous propose de
l'écouter au niveau des commerçants les
commerces physiques les magasins dont le
risque de damas qui est relativement
limitée pas compte sur internet oui il
faut faire attention aux arnaques sont
plutôt calmes mature pour rester dans
les magasins vraiment physique ce sont
quoi des prix qui sont gonflés juste
avant les soldes alors abel est gonflé
c'est comme ça c'est difficile sous les
pas c'est que bon un article qui est
proposé en solde il doit avoir été mis
en vente un mois avant et donc le prix
de
avec de soldes soldes est bon il ya un
pourcentage qui sépare en référence à ce
au prix du mois précédent alors si les
commerçants à augmenter ses prix deux
mois avant l'affectif dans la wii ça
peut être un peuple pour ceux qui
voudraient vous alerter en tout cas
avoir plus de renseignements prendre
rendez vous il ya un service que vous
avez développé sur internet justement
oui donc je veux donner l'adresse d'en
face à surnoter voilà us et 78 des
points org et donc grâce à ce service
donc qui est un soliste des deux
conseils en ligne donc tous les
consommateurs peuvent nous saisir et
donc avec l'équipe de juristes que nous
avons à versailles donc nous engageant
réponse sous 48 heures dans votre
travail c'est d'accompagner ou vous
menez des actions collectives également
alors on la campagne jusqu'à présent
c'étaient des actions individuelles mais
maintenant on sait que l'action de
groupe est entré en
il reste encore quelques décret 1 est
donc très prochainement oui on pourra
tenter des actions de groupe donc et
défendre un nombre important de deux
jusqu'à non ça va changer la donne ça
donnera plus de pouvoir aux
consommateurs aux cinéphiles sur cris de
bien sûr
85% des français se disent favorables au
don d'organes mais 50% de la population
n'a pas encore déclaré son choix face à
ce paradoxe l' agence de biomédecine se
mobilisent
l'enjeu est de taille en france l'an
dernier sur dix neuf mille personnes en
attente de dons seulement 5000 200
greffes 559 personnes inscrites sur les
listes sont décédés faute de greffon est
disponible nous en avons parlé cette
semaine
avec le docteur thierrée c'était
toujours sur ce plateau la plupart des
gens sont d'accord sur le principe du
don d'organes mais quand il s'agit de se
positionner les gens n'y pensent pas ne
le font pas ce qui pose de gros
problèmes lorsqu'on a les entretiens
avec les proches parce que quand les
proches ne savent pas ce que la personne
décédée voulait
la réflexion qu'on entend très souvent
c'est je ne sais pas ce qu'ils voulaient
je ne prends pas la décision à sa place
donc on se retrouve avec des taux de
refus toujours supérieure à 30% en
france quasiment ce taux là aussi dans
les yvelines et même à versailles et
c'est très dommage parce que le nombre
des personnes en attente d'un organe
vital sont des organes vitaux ne cesse
d'augmenter d'une manière exponentielle
extrêmement inquiétante quarante mille
personnes vivent grâce à un don
d'organes actuellement si je me trompe
pas dans les chiffres mais on se passe
le quotidien pour eux le quotidien se
passe le plus souvent bien il ya
toujours des problèmes de rejet est
évident que ces personnes vont prendre
des comprimés contre le rejette toute
leur vie mais il y avait une image assez
symbolique à une époque un jeune homme
qui avait effectivement dans une main
les comprimés qu'il devait prendre et
puis de l'autre côté les médailles qu'il
avait réussi je crois que c'était au
tennis de table à gagner dans le sport
qu'il pratiquait avant après ce sont des
gens qui vivent qu'ils doivent prendre
plus de précautions que les autres parce
qu'ils sont un petit peu plus sensibles
mais la vie reprend reprend son cours
normalement et pour revoir l'intégralité
des entretiens réalisés lors du journal
rendez vous sur notre site internet pour
les replays sont et toujours il existe
1080 un cabinet de groupe en
ile-de-france 80% se sentent fragilisés
prix des loyers trop élevés manque
peut-être de motivation aussi de leurs
jeunes collègues voici le témoignage
d'un praticien à voisin bolton
aucune secrétaire à l'accueil juste une
chaise vide c'est l'une des conséquences
des difficultés rencontrées par ce
cabinet de groupe medica la voyante
bretonneux alors qu'elle était quatre
auparavant la dernière secrétaire sera
licencié au 1er juillet en cause des
charges financières trop lourdes dans le
cabinet certains médecins vont partir en
retraite et un seul départ suffit à
fragiliser le groupe parce que les
autres médecins qui ont déjà du mal à
assurer
je n'arrive plus à
ainsi pouvoir assumer les charges
financières qui deviennent trop lourdes
d'après une étude de l'ue rps
ile-de-france -près de 30% des médecins
exerçant en groupe ont plus de 60 ans
d'après ce généraliste l'exercice
libéral n'attire plus du tout les jeunes
médecins pour une simple raison
l'évolution des mentalités je crois que
les mentalités ont changé à partir du
moment où s'est installée une politique
des 35 heures en france alors bien sûr
les médecins ne sont pas à 35 heures
mais les jeunes médecins actuelle refuse
totalement de consacrer
70 heures par semaine à leur travail ils
souhaitent améliorer leur qualité de vie
pouvoir avoir une vie de famille ce qui
n'était pas toujours le cas de nos
générations à nous c'est l'une des
raisons essentielles ce cabinet a
voisins le bretonneux n'est pas un cas
isolé toujours d'après une étude de l'ue
rps 80% des cabinets de groupe médicaux
d'ile-de-france sont fragilisées et à
terme dans les trois ans quarante pour
cent de ces cabinets serait menacé de
fermeture selon le médecin les
difficultés serait aussi lié aux
contraintes administratives qui pèsent
sur la profession et les conséquences
pourraient être très importantes
il ya un risque réel de voir disparaître
une offre de soins dans des régions où
si
proche de celle de versailles
rambouillet où la moyenne d'âge des
médecins est très très élevé et où le
remplacement ne se fait pas ce rwasa
même
j'ai appris
le départ très proche d'un des médecins
qui ne part pas en retraite mais qui
fuit l'exercice libéral pour se réfugier
dans un exercice ses salariés beaucoup
plus confortable sans apporter de blâme
ce confrère
et si les cabinets sont moins nombreux
d'après lui les patients se dirigerait
plus dans les hôpitaux au risque de les
encombraient encore davantage une des
solutions qu'il évoque la mise en place
des contrats aidés pour les cabinets
médicaux bien qu'il soit passionné par
son métier ce médecin à 68 ans et
quarante années d'exercice aimerait bien
trouver un jour un successeur
et pour alerter sur cette situation
l'union régionale des professionnels de
santé médecins demandent aux pouvoirs
publics d'intervenir à travers une
pétition elle propose aussi des
solutions on écoute l'une de ses
représentantes également médecin à
vélizy l'inquiétude elle est justifiée
parce que on a nombreux exemples de
cabinet groupe qui ferment entre le
début on a fait une enquête entre le
début et la fin de l'enquêté avait déjà
surtout moins de six mois il y avait
déjà 3 3 cabinets qui avait fermé parce
que financièrement ce n'est pas viable
c'est ce qu'on appelle le syndrome du
cabinet vide c'est à dire que les
cabinets ont été les cabinets groupe ont
été construits dans les années 70 80 et
à l'époque où il n'y avait pas de
problème de bourthois et des médecins et
les conditions de vie étaient bons
convenable et aujourd'hui chaque fois
qu'un médecin par la retraite un médecin
libéral par la retraite il n'est pas
remplacé donc les ceux qui restent
doivent payer des loyers de tout le
monde quoi c'est comme si vous étiez
célibataire avec un seul revenu et qu'on
vous oblige à allouer un cinq pièces
donc c'est assez difficile il y aurait à
faire de sueur de deux manières quoi au
niveau des collectivités
effectivement et des skis et un dommage
pour une profession libérale mais enfin
parce que normalement on se débrouille
tout seul mais bon
dd par des loyers attractifs a
simplement ça donc de faire de nous
faire des conditions de loyers très
beaucoup plus facile que le loyer
habituel et puis je dirais bien au
niveau de vous les auditeurs qui est
aussi en général des patients parce que
ça d'auditeurs qui ne consultent jamais
intervenir auprès de vos élus auprès des
de l'asepam mais essentiellement auprès
de vos élus parce que pour dire
simplement
il faut augmenter quand même un peu le
prix de la consultation qui est à 23
euros pour un généraliste 27 que les
passions mettre la main à la poche pour
continuer à voir
je n'en sais rien ça s'est passé ces
décisions politiques je n'ai pas
mais en tout cas fait pression auprès
des élus on termine avec de la culture
samedi à carrières sous poissy le
travail de réhabilitation du château
vanderbilt sera dévoilé le projet
château éphémère a été menée autour de
l'art numérique la visite en avant
première c'est avec mathilde de capvern
du château abandonné au château éphémère
l'ancienne demeure du baron vanderbilt à
carrières sous poissy voix s'offrir une
nouvelle vie réhabilité par la
communauté d'agglomération deux rives de
seine le projet a été confié à
l'association cazin éphémère qui
restaure des espaces abandonnés en lieux
artistiques
plus qu'une mission de sauvegarde
l'agglomération souhaite en faire une
vitrine culturelle est un espace de
convivialité
mais pas seulement on a voulu aussi
avoir un état d'esprit qui était tournée
vers l'innovation donc cet état d'esprit
au fait c'était aussi de tourner un
patrimoine qui était existants vers une
utilisation qui elle était tournée vers
le futur c'est pour ça que c'était un
patrimoine qui était donc à l'inventaire
des monuments
du débattement de france est la dernière
raison c'est qu'on voulait mettre à
travers le dispositif qui nous était
proposé un dispositif de résidence
artistique
on voulait mettre en relation le
territoire les habitants du territoire
avec les artistes
particularité des lieux les artistes
vont ils y habiter à partir de septembre
avant ils devront être choisis par un
comité
ce sera une sélection comme sa
collégiale après un appel à projet qui
sera lancé
nationalement à travers les réseaux de
culture numérique mais aussi les réseaux
de l'école d'art seule condition ils
devront échanger avec la population
grâce à des ateliers gratuits certains
ont déjà pris possession des lieux comme
nicolas avec son équipe ils devront
créer une forêt numérique donc cette
forêt le mérite d'aller contre est
constitué de capteurs qui récupère le
flux de sève de végétaux la vitesse du
flux de 16 et à partir de cette vitesse
cédant aux modules raid et des
variations sonores on ferait des
variations sonores on n'a pas envie de
rester non plus que sur un seul projet
on aime bien avoir plusieurs axes et
puis en même temps avoir un côté atelier
expérimentations et création de pièces
un lieu comme ça c'est aussi c'est aussi
une chance pour un pur croiser tous les
savoirs et puissent compléter
samedi 28 juin le château ouvre ses
portes pour une avant-première les
visiteurs pourront découvrir l'art
numérique les ateliers à venir et
écouter la performance du beatboxer evra
a traversé son il analyse le rapport
passionnel qu'entretient l'homme avec la
machine
merci de nous avoir suivi sur tv fil 78
prochaine édition du 7 8 lecture en
direct lundi à 18 heures en même temps
que le match de football france nigeria
qui nous essaierons de suivre pendant le
journal d'ici là vos loisirs vos idées
sorties c'est avec à catherine sous la
tôle de 7,8 week end vendredi samedi
18h30 19h30 et 23h à lundi